[Musique]
salut à tous dans la dernière vidéo on a
vu que l'écriture inclusive était avant
tout une revendication idéologique
porter par le courant féministe radicale
aussi appelé post moderne ou post
structuraliste et vous vous demandez
peut être comment une telle aberration
idéologique a bien pu arriver jusqu'aux
institutions étatiques sans rencontrer
plus de résistance et sans avoir à
franchir la porte du débat démocratique
eh bien c'est ce que je vous propose de
découvrir aujourd'hui pour cela il faut
s'immerger dans le milieu universitaire
et en particulier dans le domaine de la
sociologie du genre alors comme je vais
parler de post structuralisme
je vous invite d'abord à regarder la
vidéo sur l'écriture inclusive si ce
n'est pas déjà fait vous aidera à
comprendre de quoi il est question
ensuite quelques prérequis qu'est ce que
le genre
la notion de genre apparaît à partir des
années 60
c'est une notion utilisée par les
sociologues pour différencier ce qui est
biologique le sexe de ce qui est
culturel et ça permet donc d'étudier ce
qui est de l'ordre de l'acquis et les
rôles sociaux qui en découlent
par exemple les petites filles qui aime
le rose et les robes c'est le culturel
fait partie de l'éducation jean rey et
puis très vite des féministes notamment
post structuraliste ont entré dans le
milieu de la recherche sociologique
elles vont apporter leur vision
militante et le genre va alors devenir
progressivement une notion fourre tout
qui va leur permettre de contester non
seulement la division sexuée la société
mais aussi l'existence du sexe
biologique il hétérosexualité comme
normalité à ce casse ajoute qu'à partir
de la fin des années 80 le féminisme
poste structuraliste voit naître un
nouvel avatar encore plus radicale la
théorie queer la figure de proue de
cette théorie et judith butler une
philosophe et enseignant de chercheurs
en littérature à l'université de
berkeley en californie
cette théorie met l'accent sur la
multiplication des genres pour combattre
les terreaux patriarcat si ce genre pour
reprendre leur jargon
mais aussi sur le passage d'un jour à
l'autre pour ne pas figer des identités
qui deviendrait de nouvelles cases
oppressive le doubs les notions de
fluidité d'or et de nos minorités avec
la multiplication des genres jusqu'à
l'absurde ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est que butler n'est pas sociologue
elle ne passe pas sa théorie sur des
études scientifiques mais sur la
philosophie c'est une théorie purement
politique donc toute relative
en france la théorie queer sur un
produit très en retard à la fin des
années 90 début 2000 via l ouvrage phare
de bateleur trouble dans le genre
aux usa ce qu'elle va donner un nouveau
champ d'étude les queer studies et en
france la théorie queer ne va pas
s'assumer et va se fondre dans la
sociologie du genre déjà très politisé
contribuant à rendre le domaine encore
plus flou c'est bien qu'aujourd'hui en
france quand on lit une étude ou une
recommandation officielle portant sur le
genre on ne sait pas toujours de quoi il
est question
version sociologique soft ou version
post structuraliste c'est pour ça que la
droite parle de théorie du genre qu'on
peut comprendre comme étant le versant
politique de la sociologie du genre plus
qu'à théorie queer
maintenant que le décor est posé
essayons de comprendre comment la
théorie du genre se diffuse à partir de
l'université pour cela prenons un
exemple concret eric rey simple
enseignant chercheur sociologique et
sciences politiques à l'université paris
son nom ne vous dit peut-être rien mais
il est très connu dans le milieu
universitaire pour son mélange entre
politique et recherche et il est souvent
difficile de voir la frontière entre ces
deux activités chez lui notamment sur
ces deux sujets de prédilection le
racisme et les questions de genre il a
notamment préfacé l'ouvragé de butler
mais façon et surtout ce qu'on peut
appeler un intellectuel médiatique
il a notamment tenu des chroniques dans
différents médias papier et radio
d'après une étude de l'ina il a fait 96
passages dans les médias entre 2010 et
2016 et il est deuxième du classement
juste après patrick bruel
à côté de cela il lance aussi une des
pétitions très régulièrement
instrumentalisant au passage son statut
par exemple récemment sur la possibilité
de mettre des amendes au pouvoir ce
leurre de rue amende à laquelle il
s'oppose tout en s'affirmant féministe
il signe en tant qu'universitaire et
puis comme tout universitaire il écrit
des livres et des articles dans des
revues de recherche et il participe à
des colloques au cours desquelles les
chercheurs échange des infos sur leurs
travaux et débattent
tout cela contribue à diffuser ces
théories auprès de ses collègues et
d'une partie de l'opinion
notons aussi que son unité de recherche
n'est pas neutre politiquement on trouve
notamment la présence de louis georges
tin qui est président du cran le
collectif représentatif des associations
noires un des fers de lance de la
diffusion des idées post coloniale en
france vous savez ce nouvel anti racisme
contact souvent de racisme théorie elle
aussi issue du post structuralisme
et puis surtout à côté de tout ça eric
fassin à créer un diplôme sur mesure
pour son idéologie un master d'études de
genre est là quand on se penche sur les
enseignements on a plus l'impression
d'une formation idéologique
qu'académique le genre dont il est
question relève clairement de la théorie
du genre de nombreux enseignements
portent clairement la marque post
structure liste et d'autres sont des
enseignements sur le féminisme pas
forcément d'un point de vue historique
ce genre de master est encore assez rare
en france et les théories du genre se
diffuse surtout il ya des enseignements
spécifiques au sein de formations plus
généraliste par exemple la licence de
sociologie de l'université toulouse 2
comporte une unité d'enseignement
intitulé sociologie du genre alors
enseignement sociologique ou théorie du
genre
pour le savoir il faut jeter un coup
d'oeil à la bibliographie proposé sur
les cinq livres cités vous trouvez dans
le lot de livres de butler troublé dans
le genre ce qui constitue déjà une
indication mais vous trouvez aussi deux
ouvrages édités par des maisons
d'édition très à gauche syllepse qu'il a
disputés dont un ouvrage de christine
décrit sociologue mais qui est surtout
une militante féministe historique donc
sur cinq livres proposés on en a au
moins trois qui sont rédigées par des
auteurs radicaux et si vous comparez ce
havre biographie d'autres enseignements
par exemple celle du cours de sociologie
politique
vous vous apercevrez que cette
sociologie du genre constitue un îlot de
radicalité parmi d'autres enseignements
plus neutre et c'est par le biais de la
formation des étudiants qu'on entre dans
la diffusion massive de ces théories
car avec un bac + 3 ou bac +5 en
sociologie vous pouvez travailler dans
les ressources humaines ou autre
fonctionnaire catégorie a et quand votre
employeur voudra mettre en place des
mesures pour l'égalité hommes-femmes
votre diplôme fera de vous un expert et
vous pourrez par exemple poser
l'écriture inclusive dans votre boîte
les rares au masters de genre eux met
clairement l'accent sur cet avenir de
professionnels des inégalités et il ya
fort à parier que d'ici à quelques
années on aura toute une troupe de ces
gens dans les grandes entreprises
soucieuses de faire du gender watching
l'autre canal de diffusion
complémentaires ce sont les milieux
militants déjà par la lecture des
ouvrages politiques aux universitaires
comme troublé langue genre mais il faut
aussi penser que certains étudiants sont
aussi des militants de gauche qu'ils
soient dans des syndicats des
associations ou des partis ils vont
former d'autres militants et diffusées
ces théories qui comme par magie
corrobore leurs croyances politiques et
depuis quatre ou cinq ans sur les
questions lgbt et antiraciste les
militants sont formés
plus vivant à ces théories c'est pour ça
qu'on commence d'ailleurs à voir
apparaître sur certaines dérives
et c'est d'ailleurs l'un des paradoxes
majeur des théories post structuraliste
féministes comme postcoloniale elle
permet à ceux qui les diffusent de
bénéficier de ce que j'appelle la double
légitimité
ils sont reconnus à la fois dans le
système qui combattent et dans les
milieux militants avec la même théorie
vous avez un emploi et une
reconnaissance partisane et c'est comme
ça deux colloques universitaires aux
prises de position médiatiques de
formation d'étudiants en formation de
militants que les théories du genre se
sont discrètement diffusée jusqu'à
certaines sphères de décision en passant
par les sciences sociales
alors vous vous demandez peut-être que
faire face à cette dérive de certains
secteurs des sciences sociales bien en
tant que simple citoyen malheureusement
à grand chose cet avantage aux
institutions de réagir déjà en rappelant
à ceux qui travaillent sur la sociologie
du genre que la sociologie et la plante
de dire comment et la société et
pourquoi ils fonctionnent ainsi ils
n'ont pas me dire comment il devrait
être la question du comment devrais
peut-être la société est une question
politique qui revient aux citoyens et
pas aux experts ainsi par exemple mettre
en évidence l'éducation différentiel des
filles et des garçons veut pas dire dans
l'absolu que cette éducation
différentiel est mauvaise
la question de savoir s'il faut éduquer
les enfants tous de la même façon en
fonction de leur sexe est une question
politique qui donc vous l'avez deviné
revient aux citoyens
et puis au delà de ça il ya certaines
personnes comme eric fassin par exemple
qui en plus leur place dans des think
tank féministe quelle université
il faut dire ce qui est il ya
aujourd'hui un minimum de ménage à faire
dans l'enseignement supérieur
et c'est sur ces belles paroles que
cette vidéo se termine je vous donne
rendez-vous pour une prochaine vidéo ici
là je me portez vous bien et à la
prochaine
[Musique]